a study of yours first-ever universal
basic income experiment it's concluded
that it brings health and peace of mind
ubi is a regular unconditional payment
made to every citizen with automation
already destroying thousands of jobs
around the world a universal guaranteed
income could be a solution to rapid job
displacement liberated from the
desperate decision-making that poverty
brings ubi is believed to provide the
safety blanket needed to allow people to
pursue work as passion by learning
experimenting and innovating our current
day our current daily grind leaves no
room for such creativity the
administrative costs saved by scrapping
a large welfare state entirely could go
some way to providing funds needed and
without much of the headache the rest
would be raised by taxation ubi must
certainly come with caveats and we
should proceed with caution but
discontent over inequality will keep
rising and the political cost could be
very high if new ideas are not
forthcoming there may come a point where
the poor no longer wish to play by the
rules of the wealthy I think there's
something very attractive about the idea
that's quite counterintuitive I met some
professor of economics or something a
bit from the LSE called David Graeber
last week who's written a book called BS
I'm not saying the word jobs so the
building on the idea that there are MOOC
jobs that poor people do for very poor
wages that don't have a career ladder
the very low satisfaction and he was
arguing that about 60% of those jobs are
are also pointless now if you paid
people a modest sum of money a month to
let's say develop their intellectual
interests their training to upskill
rather than spend eight to ten hours a
day doing a job they hate I see some
virtue in that however I think this is a
problem with introducing that while we
do have a welfare state and we're trying
to introduce credits that are making
people poorer because they take have a
six-week that and don't sorry just one
thing on well on this
I think the universal basic income
they've introduced in Finland it is
about 500 pounds a month they have an
example or they've what you get if you
are on the Jobseeker's Allowance so the
question would arise why would you be on
the job seekers allowance and having to
sign on and go into an office every
fortnight if you were getting money for
not doing that
but really that Finland experiment that
was the two-year experiment and it was a
very narrow expand because was only
carried out on the unemployed and and in
Finland there they're saying it hasn't
worked because they thought it would
encourage people to go back to work
that's what they've done now is they're
looking at alternative welfare measures
but I think work gives people purpose
dignity of work incentivize people their
money Society just goes into a coma
you have people have to what you work
for minimum wage you left job because
there was there was a serve in America
big serving American people 70 percent
of them said they liked being in a
paying job and this was even people who
didn't need the money because it gave
them the dignity others were coming I
just want to say that the assumption
we're making that people won't work
isn't supported by their data and
Finland didn't meet it let me just
respond to you okay the Finnish
experiment they didn't end it it was
only ever a limited trial right it was
only ever meant to be for that period as
as a purpose to look at the research it
was always meant to end and the second
point there is it didn't show that
people were less incentivized to work
all it showed was that there was no it
didn't it actually didn't I've got the
figures with me wonderful was there's a
tiny tiny increase which was not
significant in the people that were more
incentivized so the results were
inconclusive words in Alaska the results
show people are more incentivized and we
have okay instead of you two arguing
let's hear from someone who actually
participated in this trial see me Martin
on so many words it's not a big
difference but the the sentence of
benefit being unconditional meant that I
could actually get the benefit and earn
on top of it with part-time work or any
work I think the biggest effect was
psychological so it kind of got this
idea that you have two years you have
the security of 560 euros per month and
you have to do something with that money
in the Finnish experiment by the way any
recipients who took a job continued to
get that payment as well this is absurd
magic you talked about work having to
involve learning an experiment on a
rainy day you stand at the bus queue you
wait for the bus to arrive you go to a
supermarket you go to whatever you and
your professor that you mix up with
talking about the jobs that is
incredibly rude saying there's no career
ladder because obviously you refer to
McDonald's as without go organizations
like Burger King Tesco saying through
smart suspenders they have a tremendous
process Jun Jun and I were appalled
because as part of the research yeah I
actually found out that we're all paid
the same fee so that's for Carol I've
got I found the figures that Caroline
will just use so let me just make it
very clear that in the Finnish
experiment recipients that were on UB I
worked on average forty nine point six
four days while those who were on
traditional Jobseeker's Allowance worked
forty nine point two five point five so
as I said it's tiny and insignificant
increase but it didn't work their
incentive to work quickly all I would
say is back to Carol's point we're not
factoring the factoring in the dignity
and actually what we need to do instead
to me ubi is really just a cop-out the
rich fat cats to get away with not
paying their workers properly because
actually what we should be doing is
making sure that they are paying their
workers properly and that the jobs that
will the AI machines that will take over
certain jobs we are coming up with
yeah they accuse me of saying demeaning
people who do muck jobs I'm incredibly
proud of the fact that I worked as a
checkout girl in MLS and I learn more
from her teacher I was there there are
studies about and low-income jobs and
how they are doing actually but I learnt
a lot from doing my job and I resent you
talking to me as if I'm some princess so
on the assumption this has been tried
many times before in America between 68
and 80 they trialed across six US stay
positive the opposite effect of making
people go into work and that and but
even with universally does it's a
question right this assumption that if
you if you are have a basic safety net
for income it means that you're not
going to pursue the dignity of work it's
precisely what this experiment we're
talking to finish it but debunks there
was no significant drop in people
wanting to seek or not seek to the core
of this if we don't think of another
solution to the problem of how people
can feed themselves Automation this
majors going to do other jobs were jobs
won't exist we've always supported new
industries we know that we know we can
promised I should go back to my point of
policy should be about rewarding work
not replacing it yeah but this
experiment was not about all this all
these stars is provide a safe dinner and
then people pursue paid work on top of
the UVI they're receiving heard of a
book called they absolved by a guy
called Matthew Bennett it's about
exactly this it's about whole swathes of
society being given money by the states
supposedly to meditate to go to go and
expand their minds to exercise whatever
I presume and people have hobbies people
have you just talked about who work hard
to go out and earn across they don't
have time for hobbies
yeah no no time fit that's right they
died which is a Wimpy is needed no what
we need is a job as
Maggid gives Carol a good seeding we
must move on that's almost it that
before we go there's just time for our
Straight Talk of the week now not only
is he one of the best batsmen in the
world the jewel in the English cricket
in crown and a role model for youngsters
it turns out Joe root is a thoroughly
good bloke as well this weekly cheeky
chappy England captain took time out
from scoring a glorious century to put
West Indies bola Shannon Gabriel in his
place after an altercation in the middle
for standing up against everyday
prejudice Joe root you win when you
think he's running the team he's trying
to get the monolith and he's also got
all his sensitivities you've got a
sacred impressive work by the hedging
anyway why is that part of this board
always has been or is it because you
just try and put the bloke off his
stride whether it's a bowl or the
intention that's why she took the place
that's in for this week's program but
you can join in the debate by searching
for the pledge on Facebook or Twitter
and thank you for watching